hi everyone I'm Ilana or Charl Amazon
and welcome to my channel
what are you guys watching today is my
second time recording with my Elgato
Game Capture and this is what I think is
the best thing in Grand Theft Auto 5 not
because it's the worst fun or because
it's the most well polished it's because
when I found it I was like how is this a
thing that exists so I call it people
bowling and I had my friend Matt over to
record this gameplay and basically what
you do what an Xbox 360 controller is
tap a to run and then press X to jump
and then you press B so when you press B
because it's normally the power shoot
button your character just goes yeah so
you can do it at people fires but it
must be really bad talking
then just draw the cops into my driveway
he just drove it no come yeah on the
beach it's a half I think people will
McAdams yeah why is that
Pamela's raining yeah
Wow
though I wanted trust fatality yeah
so I guess that's it for that the reason
I would call us the best is because it
just seems so out of place and I wish I
was recording it when I first found it
admittedly the effect had kind of worn
off by the time I recorded this but oh
man I loved hard when I first found it
but for real this is my second time
recording something with my algata
Game Capture as you can probably see
when you look at my channel so I don't
really know what to do with it if you
guys have any suggestions of what you
would actually like to see please let me
know I can't do walkthroughs and I can't
do Let's Plays of full games because I
just don't have the time that stuff
takes a really long time to edit and a
really long time to upload it really
only time to render and it's just time I
don't have
so if you have any ideas for videos like
this that I kind of show them please let
me know in the comments below because I
really need your suggestions and once
again thank you to el gato for sending
me the Game Capture it's such an easy
thing to use and I love it but that is
it for me today everyone I will see you
guys next time
bye